best-selling author mark Stein has been
watching the rally since the very
beginning tonight he joins us to discuss
mark what you think well I always say
the most interesting thing about Trump's
rallies Tucker are the the tonal quality
and for me it was interesting when he
decided to take it to Joe Biden with
that bit about how handlers are for
wusses
he mocked Joe Biden's folksy nurse and
said the guy comes on and says hi folks
okay that's all I got time for good
night and then his handlers are hustling
him off the stage before he mistakes
Ohio for Iowa and the question the great
question for the Democrats in 2020 is
whether the normal rules and conventions
of presidential politics which I find
boring as anything and I think most real
people do can reassert themselves
because that's the that's the choice if
you nominate Biden that you take the
stiff whose turn it is and the handlers
drag him across the finish line and it
was interesting to me that Trump said no
I'm gonna win or lose in 2020 I'm gonna
Trump is I'm gonna let Trump be Trump
and this this business with handlers are
for wusses the question is whether Joe
Biden has anything although his handlers
have anything that can sufficiently push
back against their it's hard to believe
after the experience of 2016 we're
always focused on the Republican side
where Trump came out of nowhere and
dominated the field and of course won in
the end but on the Democratic side there
was an enormous ly bitter contest where
arguably the more popular candidate
Bernie Sanders lost
thanks to rigging by the Democratic
establishment and that wound has never
really healed and so you're telling me
that that party is gonna do the same
thing again replacing Hillary with Joe
Biden and Elizabeth Warren and Bernie is
gonna stand there and take it you think
really think that's gonna happen
well I think they're they're serious
about nursemaiding Joe Biden through to
a debate with Trump and if you look at
last time around Trump himself was being
slightly
house-trained and handled during those
debates with hillary what we see in
these debate what we see in these
rallies is we see him liberated and
sometimes that works in quite ingenious
ways if it's true that he just improvise
improvise the line about preexisting
physicians I'm actually quite envious of
that that's of a confessional that's a
professional level line and I don't know
I'm kicking myself for whatever it is
now nine years ago when they rammed
Obamacare down the throats of the
American people and they said if you
like your doctor you can keep your
doctor I wish I'd come up with you oh
yeah that we will be covering
pre-existing conditions but not
pre-existing physicians sometimes there
is an innate junior genius into letting
him just stand there and rock and roll
and sometimes he will say things like
when he was citing our friend Lou Dobbs
his opinion that Trump is not just a
great president he's greater than Reagan
and he's greater than Lincoln and he's
greater than Washington and you think to
yourself well maybe that's not the sort
of thing a prudent man says about
himself but you take it you have to take
him in full and they're betting that in
full
he beats whatever the Democrats have and
that's and you see that in the
confidence on the t-shirt standing
behind him are people are wearing
t-shirts saying read the transcript in
in other words he's factored in okay the
house is going to impeach me so what and
in that sense he's cookies being
completely different for example to the
way Bill Clinton reacted to impeachment
20 years ago which was to ignore it was
happening it one thing that he's not
ignoring that everyone else in the media
is ignoring is what's happening in the
state of California and so for our
viewers who didn't see it's really quick
I just want to play this clip he went
after Pelosi on this question here it is
Nancy oughta stop wasting time go back
to her district in San Francisco help
the homeless
get rid of the drugs get rid of the
needles that are lying all over the
street and all of the things that are
washing into the ocean through their
storm sewer system what's happened to
San Francisco and what's happened to so
many other places run by the radical
left Democrats it's unbelievable it just
strikes me nobody else's is talking
about this except him no well and and
you take' because you've noticed that
your state California the Golden State
isn't so golden it's actually it's
cities are turning into decrepit
third-world cities where flesh-eating
diseases and tuberculosis and human
fecal matter stalk the streets and this
is this is absurd this he's right to
hang this race Rick if you go just say
if you go to Nancy Pelosi San Francisco
eat god worse on Nancy's what is what
she wants to do to America the middle
class dies the most populous state rots
and catches fire and goes darken nobody
says anything about it it's amazing
hey mark Stein it's great to see you
tonight thank you for that
thanks a lot Tucker